- Go. - Hi, I'm Matt. This is Tom.
And we're playing Chess Clock Jenga.
Chess Clock Jenga is a massive improvement
on --
how did you do that that fast?!
Chess Clock Jenga is a massive improvement
on regular Jenga.
You lose if... aah!
...if your timer runs out on your clock on
the chess clock.
Or if you knock the tower over.
Now, chess clocks work -- for those who don't
know --
by having two separate clocks
that only count down on your own turn.
So currently... we're pretty much exactly
tied.
'Cos I had a couple of difficult moves,
Matt had a couple of difficult moves,.
but right now his clock is counting down -- 40
seconds --
and mine isn't. So I've got a little bit of
breathing space,
a little bit of time!
But... that doesn't mean I can't still lose
if I do something like that.
And the trouble is, Matt is very good at finding
that block
that is just not 'in there' with the rest
of the tower.
And having said that, Matt, you're still ten
seconds behind me.
Oh... oh, of course you got that one. Right,
wonderful.
Can I take the... yes! Yes, I can take that
one.
So you can't take from the top two levels,
same with regular Jenga,
but -- there we go...
But other than that, any block is fine.
Matt, you are still ten seconds... uh-oh.
God, I'm loads behind. Tom, you've got 25
seconds on...
I'm fine(!) 17 for you. It's absolutely fine.
13 seconds, Matt.
So all Tom needs to do is not make the tower
fall over
and my timer will run out quickly.
Oh, assuming I can find a block to move...
Aah! Aaaah!
15 seconds, Tom.
Okay. No, I'm fine. I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm
fine...
12 seconds, Matt.
10 seconds, Tom.
Aah! No! It's good, it's good, it's good,
I'm fine...
Five... four...
Five! Four! Three! Two!
Ah, come on!
And that is Chess Clock Jenga.
So much better than the original.
[Translating this video? Add your name here if you'd like credit!]